creo que en general todos estamos
razonablemente familiarizados con los
tres estados de la materia bueno en
nuestro día a día a temperaturas muy
altas obtenemos un cuarto estado de la
materia pero los tres con los que
normalmente tratamos son el sólido
sólido ok el líquido y lo voy a poner
con color azul el líquido
y dos líquidos y ojo no forzosamente el
líquido es de color azul
pero bueno sólido líquido y gas y gas
bien pues vamos a trabajar con esos tres
conceptos generales y creo que el agua
es mi ejemplo favorito porque siempre me
viene a la mente el sólido ocurre cuando
las cosas son más frías así que déjame
ponerlo así a frías frías ok y después
mientras se van calentando ok
mientras más temperatura tengamos
entonces vamos a pasar de estar en el
estado sólido al estado líquido y por
último al estado gastón de aquí tenemos
cosas más calientes
ok y bueno cuando nosotros pensamos en
el agua en el caso del agua cuando el
agua está en estado sólido bueno a eso
le llamamos hielo hielo ok eso lo
sabemos por otra parte cuando el agua
está en estado líquido
bueno pues simple y sencillamente se le
llama a agua líquida sé que lo voy a
poner con este color agua líquida
líquida ok y bueno cuando el agua está
en estado gaseoso es decir está muy
caliente lo podemos llamar vapor vapor
de luz ahora vamos a pensar un poco
sobre esto al menos en el caso del agua
y la analogía se extenderá para otro
tipo de moléculas que es lo que hay en
el agua que hace que ésta sea sólida
cuando está más fría y lo que permite
que sea líquida y bueno hacer franco los
líquidos son cosas fascinantes porque
nunca los puedes establecer supongo que
bueno es la mejor forma de verlos y el
gas vamos a dibujar una molécula del
agua así que si por aquí tienes un
oxígeno vamos a poner lo justo por aquí
y bueno aquí tenemos el oxígeno pero
tenemos algunos enlaces también con el
hidrógeno así que a tengo aquí un enlace
con el hidrógeno ok y vamos a poner el
otro por aquí por aquí tengo mi otro
enlace con mi otro hidrógeno
también tenemos dos pares extras de
electrones de valencia en el oxígeno
recuerdas por aquí tengo otro par ok
este es uno y aquí está el otro además
hace un par de vídeos dijimos que el
oxígeno es mucho más electro negativo
que el hidrógeno ya que le gusta atraer
a los electrones a pesar de esto muestra
que están compartiendo electrones vamos
a ponerlos por aquí con este color voy a
poner que comparten aquí y aquí
electrones y aquí y aquí también
electrones en ambos lados de estas
líneas y bueno puedes observar que el
hidrógeno está aportando un electrón y
el oxígeno está aportando un electrón en
ambos lados de esta línea pero sabemos
por la electro negatividad o la electro
negatividad relativa del oxígeno que
está atrayendo a estos electrones así
que los electrones gastan mucho más
tiempo alrededor del oxígeno que del que
gastan alrededor del hidrógeno y lo que
resulta es que del lado del oxígeno de
la molécula terminas anp y déjame
ponerlo con este color
terminas con una carga parcial negativa
ok
aquí vamos a tener una carga parcial
negativa mientras que en el lado del
hidrógeno terminarás con una carga
ligeramente positiva una carga
ligeramente positiva ya que también una
carga ligeramente positiva ahora si
estas moléculas tienen muy poca energía
cinética no se están moviendo mucho
alrededor de un conjunto entonces los
lados positivos de los hidrógenos estos
están muy atraídos por el lado negativo
del oxígeno en otras moléculas
cuando hablamos sobre el estado entero
de toda la materia en realidad pensamos
sobre cómo las moléculas están
interactuando las unas con las otras
dentro de una molécula solo dibuje una
molécula del agua pero podrá dibujar más
moléculas del agua ahora déjame atrapar
esta molécula del agua así que vamos a
atrapar la am la voy a tratar como por
aquí ok y vamos a golpearla y apagarla
porque porque si yo tengo aquí vamos a
decir que el hidrógeno va a estar cerca
de esta otra molécula de agua
aún la podemos poner más o menos como
por aquí vamos a ponerla más o menos
como por aquí y para esto déjeme bajar
la pantalla bajemos un poco más la
pantalla para que veas a lo que me estoy
refiriendo
yo voy a apuntar aquí a esta estructura
pero también por tener por acá otra de
ellas vamos a ponerla más o menos como
por aquí este oxígeno lo voy a poner lo
más cerca que se pueda de este otro
hidrógeno ok y es más para que sigamos
entendiendo bien qué es lo que está
pasando aquí voy a poner otra más aquí
voy a poner otro oxígeno que esté cerca
de estos dos hidrógenos de lugo y bueno
esto es porque el oxígeno tiene carga
parcial negativa y el hidrógeno tiene
carga parcial positiva entonces si te
das cuenta justo por aquí este oxígeno
puede estar conectado con este hidrógeno
o en su lado caso por ejemplo este
oxígeno puede estar conectado con estos
dos hidrógenos porque tienen su carga
parcial positiva pero puedes ver una
especie de estructura cristalina que se
está formando y para eso déjame dibujar
estos enlaces estos enlaces son enlaces
polares aunque se empiecen a formar
y ponerlo así aquí se va a formar un
enlace polar por aquí vamos a tener otro
enlace polar y por acá otro enlace polar
ok estos enlaces polares se forman
porque las propias moléculas son polares
se puede ver que se forma una estructura
cristalina y si cada una de estas
moléculas no tiene una gran cantidad de
energía cinética o podremos decir que la
energía cinética media de esta materia
es bastante baja y bueno recuerda que
sabemos a qué energía cinética me estoy
refiriendo a la energía cinética media
hablada sobre la temperatura entonces
esta estructura cristalina será sólida
estas moléculas no se moverán una con
respecto a la otra y podrá dibujar
muchísimas más pero creo que ya
entendiste el punto de lo que estamos
formando en este tipo de estructura
mientras estamos en el estado sólido
cuando agregamos energía cinética es
decir cuando agregamos calor lo que
vamos a obtener es que las moléculas
vibren solamente un poco alrededor y
para esto antes que no ponerlo así esto
me está diciendo que estas moléculas
vibran un poco aunque bueno algunos
libros de texto lo ponen con algunas
comillas de hecho lo ponen más o menos
así esta energía cinética es la que hace
que vibren y bueno podrían vibrar
alrededor o bueno de una manera circular
alrededor y es que estoy poniendo aquí
estas flechas porque estoy pensando que
van a vibrar sin embargo recuerda que no
solamente vibran de derecha a izquierda
también pueden vibrar para arriba para
abajo o de hecho para cualquier lado
pueden vibrar y como agregaste más y más
y más calor en el sólido estas moléculas
van a mantener su estructura así que no
van a moverse una con respecto a la otra
pero van a convertir ese calor y ese
calor es solo una forma de energía en
energía cinética la cual es expresada
como una
acción en estas moléculas ahora si hace
que estas moléculas comiencen a vibrar
bastante y si pones suficiente energía
cinética en estas moléculas que piensas
que va a pasar bueno pues esta molécula
está vibrando bastante fuerte vibra más
y más fuerte conforme se agrega más y
más calor y esta molécula va a estar
haciendo lo mismo en esta también en
todas y en algún momento estos enlaces
polares que se tienen el uno al otro van
a empezar a no ser lo suficientemente
fuertes para contener las vibraciones y
una vez que esto pase las moléculas van
a empezar a moverse más allá de ellas
así que para eso déjame bajar un poco la
pantalla porque quiero ver qué es lo que
va a pasar ahora cuando las moléculas y
déjame poner aquí varias moléculas am
voy a poner a esta por acá ok
voy a poner a otra por acá ok am
perfecto y ahora voy a poner a otra por
acá porque ahora lo que está pasando es
algo
muy importante las moléculas van a
empezar a desplazarse esta molécula se
va a desplazar tal vez para camps ojos
siguen atraídos y tal vez ésta se mueva
algo por acá también hay un montón de
moléculas pero ahora se están deslizando
tal vez existan otras moléculas aquí
alrededor de este camino pero siguen
atraídas la una a la otra cierto a pesar
de que hemos conseguido la energía
cinética hasta el punto en que las
vibraciones pueden romper los enlaces de
los lados polares de las moléculas bueno
nuestra vibración o que nuestra energía
cinética sigue estando aquí para cada
molécula aquí también tengo vibración y
esta vibración todavía no es lo
suficientemente fuerte para separarlas
por completo están empezando a
deslizarse una sobre la otra y eso es
esencialmente lo que pasa cuando estamos
en el estado líquido
y tú tienes muchos átomos que quieren
estar en contacto entre sí muchas
moléculas pero se están deslizando estas
moléculas tienen suficiente energía
cinética para deslizarse unas sobre las
otras y romper esta estructura sólida
cristalina que teníamos bueno acá arriba
justo esta que tenemos acá arriba sin
embargo ahora en este estado si agregas
mucha más energía cinética en este punto
en este estado aún más calor entonces
qué es lo que va a pasar
bueno pues ellas ni siquiera van a ser
capaces de estar juntas y déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla porque ahora va a
pasar lo siguiente si te fijas am ahora
vamos a tener también estas moléculas
y déjame poner una por aquí ok vamos a
poner otro por aquí pero ahora ninguna
de estas moléculas se está tocando con
la otra es decir que estas moléculas
están completamente
están muy lejos las unas de las otras
antes de quitar esto y entonces más o
menos van a rebotar de una forma
independiente y esto en caso de que
tengamos un gas ideal pero am realmente
nunca se van a tocar en general en los
gases las moléculas ya no están en
contacto entre sí pero podrían chocar
las unas con las otras tienen mucha
energía cinética tanta que cada una de
estas moléculas está haciendo lo suyo y
no se están tocando creo que esto tiene
un sentido muy intuitivo si sólo piensas
en lo que es un gas por ejemplo es
difícil ver un gas no porque es difícil
ver un gas bueno porque las moléculas
están mucho más separadas así que no
están actuando en la luz me refiero a la
forma en la que actúa en la luz un
sólido o un líquido bueno probablemente
no deba usar el ejemplo con el agua en
este caso porque el hielo
bueno el hielo o en su dado caso el agua
es una de las pocas situaciones donde el
sólido es menos denso que el líquido es
justo por eso que el hielo flota
es por eso que los icebergs no caen
hasta el fondo del océano y los
estanques no están completamente
congelados pero puedes imaginarlo
con otro tipo de sustancia porque el
líquido es en la mayoría de los casos
menos denso esa es otra razón de por qué
puedes ver a través de ella mucho mejor
o no se está retractando bueno no voy a
entrar en esto demasiado pero el gas es
más obvio y esto también es cierto con
el agua la forma líquida definitivamente
es más densa que la forma del gas en la
forma del gas las moléculas van a saltar
alrededor no se van a tocar entre ellas
es por eso que más luz puede llegar a
través de la sustancia ahora la pregunta
sería cómo podemos medir la cantidad de
calor que se necesita para hacerle esto
al agua es decir cómo podemos pasar ante
este estado ok a este estado y bueno
para hacer eso ahora voy a dibujar
con más abajo lo que se conoce como un
diagrama de cambio de fase el cual es
una forma elegante de describir algo
bastante sencillo así que vamos a
dibujar dos ejes en este eje voy a poner
la cantidad de calor ok mientras que en
este otro eje voy a poner la temperatura
ok así que déjame poner que estos son
mis ejes y bueno a la cantidad de calor
casi siempre se le denota con la letra q
ahora bien también hay personas que lo
ponen con la letra h la letra h tanto
mayúscula como minúscula y bueno eso
quiere decir calor y se le ponen una
delta en frente de la h
eso hace que la delta signifique cambio
en la h
o dicho de otra manera cambio en el
calor y algunas veces también escucharás
la palabra entalpía déjame escribirlo
aquí
pero quieren también bueno suena como
empatía pero es un concepto bastante
diferente al menos en cuanto a mis
conexiones neuronales me dice la en
dalvian está estrechamente relacionada
con el calor es más podría decir que
esto lo podemos definir como el
contenido de calor con té
y don de calor ok esto es lo que
significa la entropía que en general
bueno pues es exactamente lo mismo que
el cambio de calor
podrías pensarlo de esta manera y es que
de hecho yo considero que esta palabra
la palabra entalpía bueno pues es una
palabra que realmente no deberían de
introducir en el contexto de los
primeros cursos de química porque puede
confundir a los estudiantes entalpía
introduce una palabra que no es
intuitiva dentro de su vocabulario la
mejor manera de pensar esto es como el
contenido de calor pero bueno es que en
tal pilla realmente sólo eso cambiar el
calor recuerda que todas estas cosas que
hemos hablado bastante como lo es calor
calor energía cinética energía cinética
entalpía
tal día energía potencial energía
potencial ok
bueno todas estas cosas las escucharás
en diferentes contextos y dirás pensé
que debería de usar calor pero están
hablando sobre tal plan o sobre energía
cinética pero recuerdan que todas estas
son distintos tipos de energía son
formas de energía y por lo tanto todas
estas se miden en jules cluzel
también podrían ser medidos en otras
formas pero la forma tradicional es en
jules y es que la energía recuerda que
es la capacidad de hacer un trabajo y
cuál es la unidad del trabajo bueno pues
son los bulls fuerza por distancia pero
como sea eso es otro tema
es bueno saber esta palabra entalpía
especialmente en un contexto químico
porque es usado todo el tiempo y puede
ser confuso y nada intuitivo y bueno es
que ya no sé qué es lenta el piano en mi
día a día solo piensa en esto como el
contenido de calor como sea en este en
este eje tengo bueno al calor mientras
que en este otro eje voy a tener am y
déjame ponerlo con este color voy a
tener a la temperatura
per aturar bien ahora vamos a decir que
bueno a bajas temperaturas vamos a
suponer que estamos como por aquí y
mientras agregué calor mi temperatura
subirá
estás de acuerdo la temperatura es la
energía cinética media así que vamos a
decir que estamos en un estado sólido
como por aquí y para eso dejamos
utilizar este color vamos a estar en
estado sólido como por aquí y mi
temperatura va a subir por lo tanto mi
calor también va a subir supongamos que
llegamos hasta este punto recuerda que
el calor es una forma de energía por eso
cuando nosotros estábamos pensando
en este diagrama que tenemos justo hasta
acá arriba en este diagrama de aquí
arriba
bueno pues recuerda que estamos en
estado sólido y cuando agrego calor a
estas moléculas que es lo que pasan
estas moléculas empiezan a vibrar aún
más o les hizo tener una mayor energía
cinética media y eso es lo que es la
temperatura una energía cinética media
así que si bajamos de nuevo justo a este
diagrama que tenemos por aquí bueno que
es lo que está pasando vamos a aumentar
la temperatura aumenta nuestra energía
cinética y estamos hablando de la fase
sólida así que déjenme apuntarlo aquí
estamos hablando de la fase sólida
sólida o del estado sólido de la materia
sólido muy bien ahora algo muy
interesante ocurre justo en este punto y
déjame ponerlo con este color en este
punto de aquí va a ocurrir algo muy
interesante que pasa a los cero grados
bueno en este caso estamos justo aquí en
este punto en los cero grados si estamos
al lado del agua en los cero grados
celsius o podemos pensarlo como 273 y
bueno déjame ponerlo aquí 273 punto
quince kelvin pues el sólido se va a
empezar a derretir y bueno si nosotros
estamos pensando en la cuestión del agua
en el hachero son así que si este de
aquí es hielo a meterme ponerlo si este
equipo es hielo ok
bueno pues qué es lo que va a pasar y
ojo no todos los sólidos son hielo
aunque podrías pensar
una piedra con magma sólida porque eso
es lo que es
podría tomar esta analogía a un montón
de formas diferentes pero lo interesante
es lo que ocurre a 20 grados si vamos en
esta dirección o en la dirección
contraria es decir si estamos en el
punto de congelación del agua o en el
punto de fusión del hielo bueno algo
interesante ocurre en este momento puedo
añadir más calor pero la temperatura no
sube por un periodo pequeño por un
periodo corto la temperatura se mantiene
constante hasta llegar a este punto de
aquí y luego mientras la temperatura es
constante se mantiene en un sentido
sólido el sólido se va derritiendo y
justo aquí es donde se convierte en un
estado líquido es decir se estaba
derritiendo todo este tiempo es la mejor
forma de pensar sobre ello y ahora
cuando estamos en este punto bueno pues
entonces ahora nuestro líquido va a
obtener más y más calor es decir va a
empezar a aumentar nuestra temperatura
hasta llegar a a
más o menos por acá el líquido se
empieza a calentar demasiado bueno y
ahora que otra temperatura se vuelve
interesante de nuevo para el agua si
llegamos a este punto de aquí y déjame
ponerlo con este color ahora llegamos a
este nuevo punto de aquí bueno este
valor de aquí nos va a dar los 100
grados celsius o 373 que bien y como
estamos más familiarizados con los
celsius lo pondré así ok
en este punto de aquí y bueno qué ocurre
esta es la temperatura a la cual el agua
se vaporiza o en la cual el agua hervida
pero realmente están consiguiendo
energía cinética mente activa y justo
igual que cuando fuiste de sólido a
líquido hay una cierta cantidad de
energía que necesitas agregar al sistema
y de hecho es una buena cantidad de
energía cinética en este punto vamos a
ponerlo así tengo ahora una gran
cantidad de pasto por acá de energía
cinética a la cual le vamos a agregar a
este punto hasta llegar aquí justo aquí
estamos pasando del estado líquido al
estado
gaseoso en donde el agua se está
convirtiendo en vapor pero ojo no se
está poniendo más caliente pero ojo no
está aumentando nuestra temperatura
notamos que la temperatura no subió y
hablaremos de esto en un momento sobre
qué es lo que está pasando aquí ahora
finalmente después de este punto el agua
está completamente vaporizada ya que
estamos en vapor podemos seguir
calentando y calentando y déjame ponerlo
con un nuevo color aun con este de aquí
podemos seguir calentando y calentando
todo esto así que la pregunta
interesante de todo esto es que está
pasando justo aquí y bueno es que pero
de esta manera aquí estamos aumentando
una cierta cantidad de calor y nuestra
temperatura está aumentando por aquí
estábamos convirtiendo nuestro calor en
energía cinética la temperatura es la
energía cinética media pero aquí justo
aquí que es lo que está pasando estamos
aumentando nuestra cantidad de calor
pero no estamos agregando energía
cinética al sistema la temperatura no
está
en incremento por lo tanto el hielo
solamente va a pasar de estado sólido a
agua líquida así que lo que estaba
pasando en este estado y para eso déjame
subir de nuevo a toda esta pantalla
porque quiero que te fijes en el estado
sólido lo que va a pasar justo en este
momento y estamos justo por aquí es que
la energía cinética el calor está siendo
utilizado para romper estos enlaces
vamos a quitar cada uno de estos enlaces
y esencialmente trae las moléculas a un
estado de energía más alto así que si
dices sal que significa un estado de
energía más alto bueno lo que pasa es lo
siguiente si no hubiera existido todo
este calor y toda esta energía cinética
entonces estas moléculas seguirían
tendiendo a estar muy cerca de las unas
de las otras te voy a dar un ejemplo
quiero estar siempre muy cerca de la
superficie de la tierra pero ahora
cuando me pones en un precipicio
tienes que ponerme en un estado de
energía superior porque tengo mucha más
energía potencial
el potencial para caer hasta la tierra
de igual manera cuando mueves estas
moléculas aparte y vas de un estado
sólido a un estado líquido quieren caer
la una hacia la otra pero cuando tu
aumentas la energía cinética no son
capaces de hacerlo y entonces su energía
sube y se rompen estos enlaces y en
teoría podría haber algo de trabajo aquí
así que lo que pasa aquí es que cuando
aportamos calor y bueno si ahora
regresamos justo hasta acá abajo ok
vamos a regresar a este diagrama que
tengo aquí bueno pues ahora date cuenta
que lo que está pasando justo en este
momento en este momento que era lo que
nosotros nos preguntábamos es que
estamos aportando calor pero esta
cantidad de calor que estamos aportando
que por cierto que por cierto se llama
calor de fusión y déjame ponerlo con
este nuevo color a este de aquí es el am
y déjame ponerlo aquí si todo esto de
aquí hasta acá y así estoy aquí es lo
que se le conoce como el calor
de de fusión fusión justo este esto es
porque es la misma cantidad de calor
independientemente de en cuál dirección
vayamos cuando vamos de sólido a líquido
ves esto como un calor de fusión cierto
es el calor que necesitas para poder
derretir el hielo y convertirlo al
líquido cuando estás yendo en esta
dirección en dirección contraria es el
calor que tienes que sacar del agua a
cero grados para convertirla en hielo
así que estás tomando esa energía
potencial y estás trayendo a las
moléculas cada vez más cerca las unas a
las otras
eso sí vamos en esta dirección y bueno
es más lo puedes pensar de la siguiente
manera podrías pensar que de aquí desde
aquí hasta acá hasta que a justo hasta
que todo esté este calor se está
convirtiendo en energía cinética pero
cuando llegamos a este punto y estamos
de aquí a acá lo que está pasando es que
el calor lo vamos a invertir en energía
potencial es justo cuando tenemos
de fase de sólido a líquido este calor
está siendo utilizado para agregar más
energía potenciar el sistema es decir
para apartar las moléculas si me aparta
semi de la tierra me estás dando energía
potencial porque la gravedad me quiere
tirar de nuevo a la tierra e inclusive
podría ser trabajo cuando estoy cayendo
de nuevo la tierra una cascada por
ejemplo hace trabajo puede mover una
turbina podrías tener un montón de
personas que serían en salman khan
cayendo también y moviendo una turbina
entonces una vez que esté completamente
líquido justo aquí ahora el calor una
vez más está siendo utilizado para tener
energía cinética que es toda esta parte
de aquí y de nuevo llegamos a un punto
que es este punto de aquí en el cual las
moléculas quieren desvincularse por
completo el uno del otro y recuérdalo lo
teníamos justo acá arriba aquí las
moléculas se quieren alejar cada vez más
las unas de las otras y entonces
llegamos a este nuevo punto y en este
nuevo punto es lo que se conoce como el
calor de
vaporización y déjame ponerlo con este
color
aquí tenemos ahora nuestro calor calor
de vaporización de vapor y la acción
porque en este punto está ocurriendo la
misma idea antes nos deslizamos uno
junto al otro ahora nos estamos
separando por completo y bueno ahora que
llegamos justo a este punto ahora de
aquí acá de nuevo estamos agregando
energía cinética lo cual lo podemos ver
como que estamos calentando cada vez más
el vapor y ahora el agua que está en
estado gaseoso solo se está poniendo más
y más y más caliente pero lo interesante
aquí o al menos lo que a mí me pareció
más interesante cuando aprendí esto por
primera vez es que siempre que pienso el
agua a cero grados voy a decir oh debo
de tener hielo pero recuerda no
necesariamente es el caso si empiezas
con agua y las escasas
es más fría a cero grados esencialmente
estás tomando calor fuera del agua
puedes tener agua a cero grados y que
todavía no se haya convertido en hielo y
eso es muy importante
estaríamos justo aquí y de la misma
forma podrías tener agua a 100 grados
que no se haya convertido en vapor
todavía tienes que agregar más energía
como también puedes tener 0 grados de
agua de cualquier modo espero que esto
te dé un poco más intuición sobre cuáles
son los diferentes estados de la materia
que hay y en el próximo vídeo hablaremos
sobre la cantidad de calor exacto que
hace falta para avanzar en esta línea y
tal vez podemos resolver algunos
problemas de cuánto hielo es posible que
necesitemos para hacer nuestra bebida un
poco más fría